commencez par je soutiens de la part de
nos amis de nos partenaires avec des
paroles extrêmement en cours tentent
avec des actes concrets tous les jours
toutes les nuits je parle ou dirigeants
du monde entier 1 ou dirigeants des
entreprises du monde entier
l'ukraine soutien de l'aide dans cette
mairie je me suis entretenu avec le
président bailly doit je suis
reconnaissant envers
damas et donné ce qu'il fait sur le
crâne et aux européens concernant les
lensois sciences de nouvelles sanctions
je me suis entretenu avec des sénateurs
américains le 2 200 personnes qui
étaient absolument généreuse et ou
proposer de l'aide concrète
déclaration routine on renforce à neuf
puisque la lumière d'un à sonera six ans
l'emporté sur les ténèbres mais ils
héritent qu'on vient de fermer l'espace
aérien pour pouvoir protéger l'ukraine
contre les avions en effet il convient
d'avoir davantage d'avions voire amère
otg le ciel de l'ukraine et de l'europe
j'ai parlé au premier
jury non
approfondir les questions du soutien le
premier ministre de l'albanie d'israël
de la ville camille nous l'ont promis
ils se
tiendront effectivement des demi moore
missiles supplémentaires nous y avons
safari jacques boudon tue l'avenir
puisqu'il nous attendra a prévenu la
victoire j'ai parlé avec des dirigeants
des entreprises
les plus importantes dans le monde ni de
gens qui l'adorent partie du monde de
l'entreprise
a produit peut proposer une double
protection et même une triple protection
contre les ukrainiens nous avons déjà
choisi notre avenir par contre qu'ils
emportent c'est d'obtenir aujourd'hui
c'est de tenir cette frontière entre la
vie et l'esclavagé ce n'est pas
uniquement notre choix les citoyens
russes et on leur choix également dansé
orient ses mimines ira entre la ville et
entre les lavages les jeunes une idylle
maintenant l'heure lorsque tour a
basculé issoise à l'emporter il vaut
mieux effectuer dans la démocratie
photos que dans le goulag visiter shirt
cette opportunité utiliser les amis les
réseaux les réseaux sociaux les connaît
ces gens là doivent pouvoir entendre ce
message nous sommes les ukrainiens il
nous souhaitons la paix si chère citoyen
russe c'est la lutte n'ont souvent pour
le trésor et la lutte tout votre pays
pour le meilleur ce que vous demandez ce
que vous avez vous pour la liberté pas
pour la prospérité votre prospérité pour
utiliser maintenant
vous vous ferez pas uniquement pour les
prix remontent au malheur s'il vous
plaît chez nous on dit non aux
restrictions yake et bien prisonnier
nous avons saisi c'était des parmi eux
il y avait des pilotes qui frappe les
gens avec des bombes non nous avons
entendu leurs témoignages nous avons vu
lors de tes passions je leur carte
c'est tout cela ce n'est pas une
improvisation tout cela on ce n'est pas
une fabrication 100 mais c'est la
réalité de la guerre salut c'est la
réalité des violations a cerné tous mes
gars y ait au port mario potes en témoin
et deux grosses de les gros centres
villes ukrainiennes ont façon mal au mal
ah bon ce soit mais cela était planifié
mais cela va pas mettre un terme à notre
humanité va pas nous tuer cela nous est
ce que comme pour blessés dont la
convention de partenaires malgré les
frappes art russe ou bien le russe nous
tenons il faut que je revienne à
serkadji mais s'il est tous les jours
qui frappe les civils qui vont rappeler
ville choristes neige est tombée aux
impies au bridge atteint même les villes
dans les ici ou dans le sud est se
prépare à bombarder la ville de dessin
au dessin d'el hadji qui a toujours
accueilli les visiteurs qui proposait je
suis qualité toujours et manoirs les
bombes sont contre reconnaissant les
recours vise au départ c'est un crime de
guerre c'est un crime historique chez
revue plaignants cela fait déjà onze
jours que nous nous battons pour notre
pays mais à de nombreux bons et nous
allons maintenant
réfléchir comment nous allons
reconstruire notre pays nous avons déjà
créé une
4ème pouvoir reconstruire lis dans vos
structures de l'otan enfin et pour
transformer notre économie pourra payer
non étatiques et pour pouvoir soutenir
les entreprises il avait d'autres
programmes aux vars unis à cenon citoyen
ces héros qui lui tournant trimestre
tandis que le début maintenant nous
avons besoin de nos forces de la sagesse
de la volonté de la victoire de l'apeg
la paix pour pouvoir conserver le cren
gloire à l'ukraine